hey everyone how's it going and Happy
New Year the 2020 is a new decade it's a
new year there's a lot of cool new
energy that's going through and I wanted
to talk about my 2019 reflections and my
2020 aspirations in this video also I
would call that skill share is a sponsor
of this video thank you so much for
sponsoring skill share so at the very
end of 2017 I posted a video called get
ready for 2018 with me where I put my
makeup on and I talked about my
reflections for the past year and then
also aspirations for the next year and I
wanted to do that same thing because I
thought that was kind of fun so in this
video I'm going to put my makeup on
while I talk about my reflections on
2019 as well as my aspirations for 2020
there's not gonna be a lot of like
coding software engineering related
content in this video it's really just
gonna be me talking about me in my
personal life but I hope that you enjoy
it regardless and without further ado
let's get started all right so I'm quite
a bit jet-lagged because I just got back
from Japan like two or three days ago so
I'm very excited to make this whole
thing come back to life again with the
power of some makeup so I'm not wearing
any makeup with my face right now but I
do have some skincare stuff on I've just
got a toner from Haddad elbow that I
like and then an all-in-one organic
essence from Muji that I've been using
forever and then I creams I'm starting
to get to that age where I just want to
have my eyes not be so puffy and dark
and if it says it's going to brighten
and deep off my eyes and gosh darn it
I'm going to use
so the makeup I'm gonna do today is the
makeup that I've been doing daily for
the last couple of months and it's
actually gotten a lot simpler since my
last reflections video so this should go
by pretty quick I'm going to start off
with some 2019 reflections and some
concealer okay so I wrote out all the
things that happened in 2019 as I
usually do with all of my years of what
had happened that year prior and I came
up with a shorter list but I'll list
with lots of different things that are
very vague and meaningful to me than in
previous years
so I'm just blending this real quick and
some of the things that I really wanted
to highlight that happened in 2019 was a
lot of great things happen for this
YouTube channel and for the things that
I do related to this YouTube channel
like for instance I did my very first
ever conference talk which was super fun
super exhilarating and very challenging
that I was really excited to be a part
of at try Swift conference in Tokyo in
March and this is like my first ever
time giving a talk at a tech conference
and I actually gave that same talk a
couple months later at a conference
called all comms and that one recently
won an award the hacking with Swift most
inspiring presentation award which I'm
super proud of but that was a really fun
talk to give and something that I wish
that I could give like my younger and
former self that talk there's actually a
video of my talk online on YouTube so
I'll link that up here and then I also
made a vlog of my experience talking at
a tech conference first time so I'll
leave that in the description box down
below all right now that concealer is
done I'm going to move on to foundation
which is really just a tinted
moisturizer that I've been using that I
super-duper-duper love this is Laura
Mercier tinted moisturizer natural skin
Perfector that makes my skin all shiny
and smooth and clean and beautiful so
I'm going to put that on some other
things that happen in 2019 that I'm
super proud of that are kind of related
to this channel I'm just gonna rattle
them off right here my ELF podcaster and
in 20
tene I went to Seattle to film crash
course which was really awesome I went
to New York City to do a thing with
built by girls and then spoke at their
summit later that year and I went to
VidCon with Jarvis and Friends which is
always a fun time and it's always a good
kind of reflection point in July of
every year for me to reflect on how far
I've come in this youtubing journey and
how excited I am to keep moving forward
personal milestones wise 2019 was a
pretty interesting year I finally went
on my honeymoon in 2019 to Scandinavia
to Sweden Norway and Denmark which was
really great I got to spend a lot of
time with Scott which was super duper
fun I also went to Japan a bunch of
times I started the year off in Japan
and then I went to Japan again in March
and then I was just in Japan for the end
of the year which is great because my
parents live there and being able to
visit as often as possible it's
something that I definitely want to do
and keep doing so it was great that I
got to go so many times this year oh I
almost forgot
that the beginning of this year I kicked
off the series how to kick-start your
software engineering career which was
like the biggest project that I've ever
done for YouTube and it was super fun to
work on and I'm really really proud of
how it came out and how it was done and
I'm glad that I did it okay back to some
personal things I continued going to
therapy I started exercising more
frequently and more consistently for the
first time since like high school I
turned 27 years old which depending on
who you are could be a big milestone ish
maybe it was like kind of an average
milestone for me as is every birthday
usually I'm almost done with this tinted
moisturizer which yeah now that I have
these lights up in my house I can
definitely see that this makes my skin
look all glowy which I'm all about that
glow
not so much about that Matt actually
nowadays and then more recently in 2019
I had a really really bad couple of
months that I'm still kind of going
through around my anxiety which got
particularly bad in November it was not
a fun time and I've kind of been trying
to regain my balance ever since but I'm
definitely making progress and I am
happy and excited to be headed where I'm
going and as a result I started
meditating every day in 2019 which I'm
really proud of because I it's something
that I've been wanting to do for a while
and I felt like this was kind of a good
time to pick that hobby up and build
that habit but yeah it's been a tough
couple of months closing out 2019 for me
to be honest
luckily I spent the last couple of weeks
with my family and that was really great
and really grounding but I think you'll
notice that in a lot of my 2020
aspirations a lot of themes around
balance and regaining footing and those
kinds of things are all very much
present in my current aspirations for
2020 because of what had just happened
overall 2019 was a good year there were
some really good times and some really
bad times as there are for every year I
wasn't expecting the challenges that I
saw and I also wasn't expecting a
happiness that I felt in 2019 and I just
feel grateful for all those experiences
I actually came up with a phrase at the
beginning of 2019 to help guide me
through what it is that I wanted to do
and to also kind of give me some sort of
direction and where I wanted to head and
I wanted to share that with you now
it's patient progress builds I kind of
just thought of this because I think at
the beginning of 2019 I was really
excited of all the projects that I had
going on and all the projects that were
on the horizon that I knew that with
patient progress I could build something
great so that's kind of what I grounded
myself on my mom wrote this which gives
it even more meaning and I feel like I
lived this pretty truly and I think it's
just something
that I'm going to bring with me through
2020 and beyond now I don't really have
a phrase for 2020 yet but I'm starting
to get there I think eventually it'll
come to me and then maybe I'll do
another thing like this okay I want to
get on to 2020 aspirations but I
realized I forgot a thing it'll get it
BRB haha I have returned with the
Almighty brow pencil which is an
important part making me look like I am
fully awake of which I am and it's 1017
p.m. and I'm supposed to be going to
sleep because I've got work tomorrow
but that is jet lag all right so let's
get on to 2020 aspirations so I'm not
really someone who sets like goals or
anything or metrics because I'm just
someone who changes a lot over the
course of the year and I know that and
it has to be that the things that I want
at the beginning of the year can be very
different from what I want at the end of
the year or even like in the middle of
the year and so I want to give myself
the flexibility I guess if I do change
like these things that I want are kind
of more evergreen or they're just things
that kind of capture the moment of like
hey at the beginning of the year these
are the things that I wanted so that I'm
patient with myself if it takes longer
and I can still be ambitious if I
accomplish them within a year I realize
that that's just something that has
worked for me that's what I did in my
2018 video and it worked pretty well I
mean I know that I definitely beat
myself up if I don't achieve certain
things but that's not the whole point of
aspirations and New Year's resolutions
especially if you know you're gonna fail
because you're like too ambitious I
think it's just like I just want to
remind myself at the beginning of the
year that these are the things that I
think would be awesome to challenge
myself to do this year whatever the
solution might
okay I'm gonna finish filling in my
brows and then I will read them to you
oh my head get a notebook which I cannot
read while I'm doing the brows if you
think I look like a completely different
person sometimes when I'm after I feel
in brows because I remember like when I
was like in high school or college I'd
wash Beauty youtubers and be like I
don't do anything for makeup that day
I'm just gonna do my brows and I was
like that's so weird cuz you just have
these stamped brows and nothing else but
now I kind of get it maybe it's just my
face looks like the way that it does now
or my tastes have developed but y'all
are right breathing youtubers if you do
nothing brows really does make a big big
difference let me do the fluff laughs
look at that so natural honestly there's
a lot of days or I just stopped right
here cuz this is fine to me a lot of
time sometimes I mean a lot of days I
don't put on tinted moisturizer either
but you know what today we're going for
it cuz we're getting ready for 2020 it
feels like it's an important year so my
number one 2020 aspiration is to rethink
and reimagine my life and lifestyle like
I said before this is kind of
reactionary to some of the anxiety that
I've been feeling recently because what
I mean by rethink and reimagine life and
lifestyle are things like making sure
that I practice grounding myself and
finding home within myself because I
noticed that when I feel very anxious I
don't and I feel very not at home and
finding a place to come back to like
mentally physically emotionally I think
is going to just be increasingly
important for me and it's maybe
something that I've lost over the last
couple of years and so I really want to
get better at that a big thing in all of
this too is just to find some more
with in my life Scott always jokes I'm
like an on or off person when you tell
me to do something I will do something
at a hundred and five or ten percent but
if I am not doing something I'm doing it
like a negative 100 percent and so I
want to be able to find happy mediums in
between that are 50 percent 60 30 20 70
like somewhere in there so that I see a
little bit more of the nuance in life
and in myself and not make sweeping
generalizations or judgments about
myself or others I think that's just
going to help me process and understand
the world better and process understand
myself better too if I give a little bit
more leeway and leniency and nuance to
things by finding balance also I'm a
Libra so balance is a very important
ingredient to my life which I don't
think I've had in a while so I'm going
to work hard on that or just try to
invite some balance into my life because
I'm not about to turn that switch all
the way on again no serene it's kind of
ironic that I'm putting all this makeup
on right now but realistically as soon
as I'm done filming this I'm gonna wash
it all off but you know what I'm trying
to get better at impermanence and
temporariness so maybe this is a good
lesson for me and my body to learn
because not everything has to have a
purpose not everything has to be like
you know you have to do it right once
and don't make any like movements or do
things that are unnecessary sometimes
you have to do things that are
unnecessary because otherwise it's just
like I don't know my life is not a
optimization program it's life and I'm
human and sometimes it's okay to just
slow down and do things that make no
sense or have no purpose because that's
fine
continuing on the rethink and reimagine
life and life style stuff finding peace
living simply and love myself for also
within those things just kind of like
taking a chill pill and just relaxing
and
loose and just living more simply and
not having so many things in my head all
the time so that it feels a little bit
more manageable and I'm not already
stressed out and I'm not always
overwhelmed those are also things that
I'm trying to do in 2020 and so an
important part of this reimagine life
and lifestyle stuff is also around
redefining who I am outside of my career
which I think a lot of my own self
definition has been around my career and
around being a software engineer heck
this whole YouTube channel is kind of
like that right now but there are so
many other aspects to myself that I
think I haven't been giving enough love
to that I haven't been giving enough
time to that I would like to do that
first just figuring out what that means
within myself before broadcasting it
before telling others before and then
affecting it in other ways and it's hard
it's a hard thing to do especially when
you live in Silicon Valley literally
everyone else out there is a software
engineer and that's what you have in
common with people but I think I need to
find other ways to connect and identify
who I am because career is not
everything it's like it's one part of it
it's important part but it doesn't have
to be everything okay last time I put my
mascara on in the video I couldn't do
anything while I did it so let me take a
quick second to do the the fluffy fluffy
is real quick
you
Oh fun fact there was a time in life
where I thought that I couldn't wear any
eye makeup because I'm someone who wears
contacts but yeah turns out you can
totally wear contacts and eye makeup at
the same time granted putting on certain
kinds of makeup is really uncomfortable
because my eyes get really dry really
quickly because I have contacts but
mascara eyeliner you can do all of those
things just fine
so other than rethink and reimagine my
life and lifestyle in 2020 the other
thing that I really want to focus on is
to foster creativity creativity is
something I've just been thinking about
a lot because I'm not sure that I've
really focused on doing that a lot but
as children as people as teenagers like
there's a lot of inherent creativity
within us I'm sure there is an aspect of
creativity that comes in coding but I
think there's also an aspect of
creativity in music in art and all of
these other things that help you to
express other kinds of creativity and
I've been really turned on to that
recently and so that's something that I
want to do more of in 2020 and
realistically that means things like
welcoming failure I need to be able to
have a beginner's mindset and be okay
with being really bad at some things at
first because that's how you're going to
learn and be creative so that you have
the tools to make cool things and so
welcoming failure I think is an
important ingredient in fostering
creativity as well as other things like
being bold and having fun with it
creativity supposed to be a fun thing
and I just want more of that in my life
the other important ingredient I think
in fostering creativity is to learn a
lot more also I'm done with my makeup so
told you that was fast it's way easier
than it was in previous years and it's
made my mornings way easier to deal with
okay so as far as learning goes some
things that I want to learn are things
like more kind of music related learning
some artistic related learning I don't
really know where that's going to take
me but
know that there's a lot of curiosity
brewing within my brain and I kind of
want to see where that might take me
even if I spend time doing things that
might not this not necessarily like help
people directly or might feel like a
waste of time I want to challenge those
notions and be able to do things that I
just inherently enjoy creating and
exploring and discovering new stuff
which leads me to the sponsor of this
video Skillshare now Skillshare is an
online learning community that offers
membership with meaning there's so much
to explore on the platform there's
projects that you do you have the
support of other creatives and
instructors that it really fosters
growth by learning on the platform
something that I really love about skill
sure is that you can learn on your own
time without meaning to put your life on
hold because we all have lives that we
can't put on hold sometimes and so being
able to do it on my own pace whenever I
want is something that's really great
and I'm excited to have on Skillshare
I'm going to be taking a lot of classes
related to creativity specifically
there's one by Chantel Martin who I've
been following for years on Instagram
because I love her art she's got a
course called drawing on everything
discovering your creative voice and I'm
really excited to take that course and
for those of you who are learning coding
or just getting into the industry there
are a lot of coding classes in Python
CSS JavaScript Android what-have-you as
well as lessons on coding interviews and
I also found some courses around how to
give feedback to your co-workers at work
which is an invaluable skill that's
really important to have as a software
engineer as well as mapping your career
and creating an action plan for where
you want your career to go these classes
and more are on scale sure for just $10
a month and if you click the link in the
description box down below then you get
two months free of your premium
membership to explore your creativity of
which I will definitely be doing on
Skillshare
so thanks to scale chair for sponsoring
this video and
I'm really excited to start fostering my
creativity in 2020 because I have a
feeling it's something that I'm gonna
keep doing for years and years to come
so those are my current thoughts and
aspirations on 2020 rethink and
reimagine life and lifestyle and foster
creativity there might be more that come
out of the woodwork as I think about it
more and needs of your progresses but
that's kind of where I'm at right now
and that's it my face my mind my body
are all ready for 2020 I really hope you
like this video if you did please hit
thumbs up and click subscribe for more
videos like this on my channel and I
hope that your 20/20 is off to a great
start let me know what your goals
aspirations resolutions are for 2020
maybe I can make some content that'll
help all of y'all so let me know in the
comments down below and I hope you all
are having a great day wherever you are
bye